ready yeah I'm in the foothills of the
dolomite mountains but on our north of
Venice in Italy and this is a place
called IP office the poplars 40 years
ago man called Bruno opened a restaurant
and then he learned to weld and he
thought okay I'll make some small bits
of playground equipment for the kids who
come to my restaurant well it's now 40
years later and Bruno's welding looks
like this this is the terrifying wheel
depth and what you haven't translated an
IP IP like all the rides at this bizarre
kinetic playground bean park it is
entirely human powered everything here
has no more energy than what people put
into it in this case by pedaling and
[Applause]
here we go oh that's my phone that's my
son let's go here we go again
so um I might have broken my phone good
news I did not break my phone bad news I
did break my face about five minutes
after filming that entirely my fault not
theirs I ran a little bit of metal I
shouldn't have done tripped fell
face-first next thing I know a lovely
Italian doctor is putting seven stitches
into my cheek obviously there's an
acceptable level of risk when you go and
do something like this if you're not
willing to take that risk then don't go
but I do recommend you go it is
wonderful everyone there was wonderful
they provided first aid as well um but
if you go please don't get reckless
don't do what I did don't think you're
invincible just as you've done a couple
of somersaults on a bike follow the
safety warnings be really careful I'll
see you around and if there's no video
next week it is because I'm having seven
stitches removed from my face